right from me darlin  [Music]  run my good wine run from me doll  you better run for your life run from me  baby  [Music]  you better run for your life did you  realize that her father was struck  raving madman and we got a foul blood in  our veins  he's just gift us my blood most part  we're good at what we do  Charlie you kill me end up with his  father or his friends either tails  it usually ends badly  we finished his last job part ways we've  had a good long run we're still alive  it's a chance to get out  and forgetting something we're the  sisters brothers and we finish the job  [Music]  watch nothing's changed  my little brother I love you you better  run for your life  [Music]